Tiffany's going to start off this hour
and Memphis hi Tiffany how are you doing
great Dave I like a listener thank you
I don't like quit well someone's what I
shouldn't for you I your phone is
breaking up try again oh I can't exactly
tell you how long this has been but I
had a creditor trying to get a hold of
someone with the same person last thing
as I do but every time that I try and
contact them the Social Security's do
not magic I never bet for a student loan
and I never went to school in
Pennsylvania and every time that I try
and contact them they basically do not
listen and then keep on trying to
contact me and I was wondering if there
was any way that you knew of to get them
to basically stop harassing because
obviously they have no idea where this
person is right okay so you have talked
to them and given them the last four
digits of your social and it does not
match my social buzz and every time I
contact them and verify it
you are one right and then they don't
they don't change their procedure okay
no so well what I would do is what I
would do is this then next time that
they call you do the same thing and then
when you're talking to the person say
listen I don't know about you but the
last four people I talk to are morons if
the rest of the people working in your
organization are morons and you are a
[ __ ] you all are getting ready to have
a problem so you need to really make a
note on this file and really get this
changed or I could talk to your
supervisor if you're too dumb to do that
because if you don't let me tell you
what's going to happen
the next time that your organization
calls here you can put this note in the
file you're not going to get a human
you're going to get a sports
airhorn and I'm going to see if I can't
break your freaking eardrums because
you're too stupid to stop calling my
house
I'm gonna file a complaint with the
Federal Trade Commission for violating
the Federal Fair Debt Collection
Practices Act and then I'm going to hire
an attorney and I'm going to sue you
personally and they're going to come to
your home and bother you address do what
maybe even gotten my address well it's
not hard to do if they have your name
yeah you know but but you basically what
you have to do is you have to pierce
through the stupidity and try to get
them to actually make a change in the
database that they're working from
because here's the problem the person
you're talking to will not be working
there in 11 days turnover ratio in a
boiler room collection agency full of
morons is unbelievable
so the chances of you ever talking to
the same human twice is almost zero in a
situation and so they just the turnover
rate is unbelievable all they do is hire
and train replacements for the next set
of morons to come in and call you
because they couldn't get a job doing
anything else so we know they're morons
and unbelievable so really you just have
to get all up in their business and then
blasts the freaking headset off their
thing if they call you again and just
you know and do file a complaint with
the Federal Trade Commission you can
ftc.gov there's a place to do that and
just light them up because it is an
industry that's out of control and the
only way regular people can handle that
is to fight back because there's no
communicating was stupid at this level
but you try it one more time put them on
notice and do just exactly what I said
and if you're any nicer than what I just
said they're not going to hear you they
do not understand anything except a tuba
for across their face and so you have to
hit them that hard to try to get two of
their brain cells to actually connect in
the conversation and just just I mean be
unreasonable because this is an
unreasonable situation you've tried nice
you've tried normal you've tried regular
and some of you sweet people are out
there going Dave Ramsey's over the top
know
you dealt with idiots at this level Dave
Ramsey's not over the top believe me
it's unbelievable what these people do
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]